in the end his defiance found its limit
as even his most loyal acolytes deserted
him andrew cuomo finally stepped down
he was not guilty of sexual harassment
he said
but rather not realizing changing
standards in society
in my mind i've never crossed
the line with anyone
but i didn't realize
the extent to which the line has been
redrawn and i love new york
and i love you and i think that given
the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back
to governing 11 women who worked in
cuomo's office have accused him of
sexual harassment
but it was perhaps an executive
assistant waiving her right to anonymity
this week
that nudged the governor from his perch
he
groped me he touched me
not only once but twice
and i don't think that that had happened
to any of the other
women the touching
it's been a short fall from grace for
andrew cuomo
12 months ago he was being spoken about
here as a potential
presidential candidate in 2024
roundly praised for his handling of the
kovid pandemic
but now he's lost the democrat party and
he's lost this city
here the only surprise is that he lasted
so long
his talks to the public were so
inspirational and comforting
so it's depressing to find this out but
of course
he should immediately resign the media
was in love with him for quite some time
there and
held him up as you know the greatest
thing since sliced bread
and now
this is not the end of the story for
cuomo he's still facing possible
criminal charges
and civil action but it is surely the
end for a political career
which couldn't be saved by even the most
stubborn defense
martha kellner sky news new york